e
e e
well good morning everybody I trust
everybody had a wonderful wonderful
weekend with the snow and the wind and
the ice and know um I had a thrilling
weekend uh Saturday uh I drove over to
uh St Lawrence University up in Canton
New York um it's a long drive about a 5
hour drive over the top of New York that
evening they got nailed with 16 Ines of
snow on top of already we're walking up
to our knees nothing was plowed on that
road at all going across Upstate New
York on Route 11 all the way to Lake
Champlain we are pushing 8 Ines of snow
on we couldn't see the highway
drove about 30 m hour tried to stay on
the road once I was off the road because
there was just nothing on the side you
didn't know where the road was and so
it's uh that was a thrill especially
when then all that ice builds up in the
front end and then it starts shimming at
about 40 m an hour you have to take it
to a garage and let it thaw
out I don't
know Al so that you could be here today
I'm really excited about sitting down
without having to look down the window
at White okay um so the first bill we
have on the DACA today we are we are
executing bills today uh first one is
112 uh hb12 it
requires uh students in the University
system and Community College systems of
the Hampshire pass United States
citizenship and Immigration Services
Civics naturalization test and I'd like
to look to uh represent Maguire for a
motion please I'm thank you Mr chairman
I move to retain I'll second that
okay we have a motion made by represent
McGuire and second by represent luno to
retain hb12 further discussion from the
make of the
motion any not particularly okay from
the
second any further discussion from
committee
members not seeing any uh Madam clerk
when you're ready we're ready
representative spills baring yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
kofalt yes representative goom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative
peoples yes representative luno yes
representative Ames yes representative
Burton yes representative f
yes representative Damon yes
representative Bry bricky yes
representative
Chan yes representative Weinstein yes
Andes and chairman lad
yes 18 y0
a any problem with
consent it's retained it's retained it's
retained so there's no report got wake
up a little bit here okay thank you very
much so that bill has been retained uh
the next bill on the dock it is 510 this
relative to establishing certain due
process rights for uh students student
organizations and faculty members facing
disciplinary actions by the state in uh
State institutions of Higher Learning
we're going to pass over this bill today
uh it will be on the dock uh next
Tuesday uh I ask that folks from the
University system the community college
system meet with us following this
meeting and we'll look at that bill 510
next one down
um looking at
659 establishing the New Hampshire
college
graduate retention incentive program and
represent philis
bery thank you Mr chairman I move itl on
HB
659 we'll second that okay we have a
motion made by representative spillsbury
and second by representative luno to it
L HB
659 uh representative spillsbury do you
have to
add not not very much unfortunately the
prime sponsor was uh unavailable at the
time the hearing occurred I think it's a
complex Bill and uh one that we're not
prepared to move ahead
with represent
luno any further discussion from
committee
members not seeing any hands when when
you're ready ready Madam
clerk representative spillsbury
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
Koval yes representative Kum yes
representative popovic yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative
peoples yes representative
luno yes representative Ames yes
representative Burton yes representative
fellows yes representative D Damon yes
than representative bricking yes
representative cran yes representative
Weinstein yes yeah okay and chairman lad
yes 18
Zer any objection to
consent okay fine thank you uh the next
bill which we have the docket is HB 770
relative to establishing a program to
earn
tuition uh credits for State of New
Hampshire higher education institutions
through community community service Mr
chair yes could we um could we just hold
off on that one till um later this
morning because I think we're it look
expecting a potential Amendment from the
prime sponsor if if you have one coming
to us we can hold off and take this at
the bottom here that'd be great um and
then we'll look at it for discussion
purposes thank you thank
you
okay okay HB
646 this is a bill requiring School 583
okay I'm okay
represent HB 583 relative to State
participation in the Medicaid direct
certification program for free and
reduced price School
meals Mr chair yes I me yes Mr chair I'd
like to make a motion of
Ideal skiping wait a
minute you wanted to pass on
that what I'm GNA first before we I take
a motion we do have an amendment here
and I'd like to open it up to discussion
not take any action on this amendment
because we've just been handed that
Amendment no that's the amendment
there the amendment here yes this
is thank you very
much okay remember that this amendment
we're going to be discussing discing but
there's no we're still in discussion
stage on
this I don't think we've seen this
amendment
before no actually Mr chair we uh we did
circulate the amendment at the uh work
session on um on these bills last week
oh we did
yep so you may already have this in your
in your
file okay uh go ahead and and once again
please then explain what what your
amendment's all about sure thank you
very much Mr chair so uh so the
underlying bills House Bill 583 which
would um which would have the uh
Department of Education apply to the um
the USDA for uh for participation in the
Medicaid direct certification pilot
program and uh what this means is um is
school districts all across the state
who uh who who are are participate who
participate in the usda's free and
reduced price lunch program would no
longer have to have uh students in th in
those districts fill out paperwork to uh
to uh uh to qualify for the program they
would be qualified by virtue of their um
their uh their U enrollment in in
Medicaid and we heard from the um the
director of um who directs the Medicaid
Program in New Hampshire that uh that
they'd be able to have an opt out um uh
you know during the um during the
Medicaid enrollment um process but um
but basically again the underlying Bill
itself would uh would identify uh an
additional proximately 10,000 students
and that's what's in the second handout
that went around that has the list of
all the cities and towns and um and it's
a little buggy that it was produced by
by um Department of Education uh uh a
year ago and um and U Mark manginello
who produced it said yeah there's
there's there's a couple um there's some
bugs in it that I think probably go in
both directions but you can see that
that throughout the state uh with
Medicaid direct certification as opposed
to just using the free and redu price
lunch um paperwork that we identify
about another 10,000 students Statewide
that would uh would qualify for free and
reduced price lunch and um and as um as
many of us who have who have you know
been involved in in school funding so
you know that what what I've just been
talking about is is basically you know
feeding kids feeding kids from lowincome
uh backgrounds uh making sure that they
can get a free reduced price lunch that
is paid for by the US Department of um
of Agriculture so um uh so the what the
amendment does and it's and it really
happens in section two here is um is it
it provides a budget neutral impact when
it comes to using the free introduced
price lunch ADM uh data uh in the school
funding formula so it would hold the
school funding formula used for the FY
26 and y 27 budget so the budget that's
being you know that the governor um
introduced last week it would uh it
would be budget neutral so it would hold
the those um those different the
differentiated Aid and the the
extraordinary needs Grant uh which are
both both calculated based on the free
introduced price lunch
membership it would hold those steady uh
based on the fy2 the current school year
that we're in so it wouldn't have any
impact on adequacy um uh had we not put
um uh section two uh in in the amendment
you'd basically see the adequacy grant
go up based on these additional 10,000
students and uh would go up by um I
think it's 20 2,300 $2,300 per 2392 so
almost
$2400 per student so it would be a $24
million impact in each of the of the two
years so the amendment makes that budget
neutral um and um and why do we want to
make it budget neutral because we feel
that the policy is very important to uh
to make sure that that number one we're
we're identifying the um uh eligible you
know students who are eligible for free
and reduced price lunch as 43 other
states um uh currently do it today we're
able to use the Medicaid data uh with a
secure uh handoff between
DHHS and um and the Department of
Education um and DHHS has testified that
they're able to put a um put a opt out
uh section in there for for Medicaid
families when they're when they're
applying if they don't want to be
considered as part of the free
introduced price lunch program so that's
that's a big reason to it the there are
two additional reasons why Medicaid
direct certification is really important
down the road obviously we're looking at
uh at doing something with the school
funding formula and uh and clearly uh
students that come from low-income
backgrounds have um uh are provide
challenges uh to school districts I like
to say you know what it costs more to
educate a thousand kids in Manchester
than it does a thousand kids in Bedford
because the challenges are different and
um and so I think we would want to as a
state since we're relying on on free
introduced price lunch membership as a
proxy for families um with students well
from students with lowincome backgrounds
that we'd want to at least use accurate
data and Medicaid direct certification
would provide that accurate data uh for
use in the school funding formula but
let's make it budget neutral we're going
to push that off for U for at least a
couple years the third thing um that's
that's important for this is that um the
the free and reduced price lunch
information is used by the
by Health and Human Services at the
federal level to calculate the child
care scholarship that the state receives
that it can give out to uh to qualified
families to help um um Child Care become
more affordable and uh and and you know
anybody that's seen the news in the last
couple days is aware of the recent
report from the New Hampshire fiscal
policy Institute uh talking about how um
how the average child care cost for uh
for two kids in childcare is running
families about $32,000 a year so um so
this brings money into the state from uh
from a Federal grant tied to free
introduced price lunch membership and um
and the Medicaid direct certification
helps us do that so so the the you know
all in all these are these are all
really good reasons why the why we feel
the the Medicaid direct certification is
important I guess one final thing and
we've never we haven't really talked
much about this is that um is that in
many cases the reimbursement amount that
school districts receive for free Andrew
price lunch is higher than their um than
their retail price that they charge for
lunch so many districts actually come
out ahead when they get when they when
they quote sell a free and reduced price
lunch meal uh rather than paying you
know the the the sticker price um you
know for that uh for that lunch so so
these are all really strong things you
can take a look at the Town by town and
um and again with the with the caveat
that it's a little bit buggy but I think
it's in General close and um and you can
see the impact uh it has in the
communities you serve and the
communities all across the state and
it's about $1,000 per student that's the
savings for families so when you take a
look at
Manchester and um and uh where do I find
it here um um Manchester seeing about an
1100 student increase with Medicaid
direct certification versus having
chasing around kids for free introduced
PR lunch paperwork that's a um you know
that's a that's a a million dollar you
know $1.1
million uh savings for uh for low-income
families in the uh in in the Queen City
so uh so we hope people will find this
this bill to be and you know something
that uh that we can move forward with as
a state with this amendment uh given the
U the bud challenges we're facing thank
you okay thank you very thank you very
much we are going to go directly into
caucus at this time so we're going to
have to clean the room out here and uh
are you going to be caucusing in the
we'll in the other room and we'll caucus
in this room thank you very much thank
you Mr ch
scop up any of the extra Jen are we
turned off upstairs the amendment and
testing
e
e e
okay we're we're out of caucus now we're
back into a full executive session and
we're back on HB 583 and I am going to
recognize representative papovich for a
motion thank you Mr chair I'll move
right on HB
583 second and if I may briefly okay
hold on a second so we have a motion
that's made by representa papovich and
second by representative Maguire
representative papovich thank you Mr
chair I just want yes you said 588 583 I
said Thank you thank you so much for
checking um I just will be brief because
we've had extensive discussions about
this bill the previous term and this
term I appreciate intent of the
amendment but at the end of the day all
it does is that it kicks the can down
the road for two years I don't think
that something that's not good policy if
adopted as is will be good policy
because we delay the massive Financial
impact for two years so for that reason
I'd like to uh move forward to the ideal
motion on the bill as is thank you is
the maker the second got anything to say
I'll just say that um there's a lot of
parts of the adequate formula even on
the right hand side that depend on free
and reduced lunch numbers and so um
changing those has a lot of
implications for
funding thank you further discussion yes
represent luno thanks very much I'm
actually really glad that you guys are
making the motion for itl and we'll
certainly be um be roll calling this and
fighting this on the floor but it does
not uh Kick the Can down the road in
fact it uh it immediately uh would uh
would begin um um enrolling uh kids from
low-income families in the federal USDA
Grant so that they can begin eating
we're talking about 10,000 kids who are
live all across the state so it begins
feeding kids immediately it also
provides the state with an accurate
number not a make believe number when it
comes to identifying the um the number
of uh of kids from low-income
backgrounds that uh that attend our
public schools and and obviously we're
all we all know that that's part of the
adequacy funding formula but with an
amendment it uh would would also
recognize the budget challenges so if
kicking the can down the road means
having it having um accurate numbers for
our funding formula yeah but that that
certainly doesn't sound like um a
financially responsible type of
statement to make the third thing it
does is um is um is directs uh more
federal health and human services money
to New Hampshire for the child care
scholar ship and we're talking about
millions of dollars that can that
families that are that are struggling uh
uh toh to pay for child care and uh we
can see from the most recent New
Hampshire fiscal policy report what
impact that has on Workforce and our
economy the for thing it does is uh is
it actually increases um revenues for
our local school districts who most of
them charge less than the reimbursement
amount for uh for a lunch so uh so this
becomes a a net positive for them and
then the fifth thing that we didn't talk
about the representative fellows um
mentioned when um when we were just
meeting is how Ida actually uses free
and reduced price lunch counts to um to
help um to help calculate the title One
funds that our that our schools uh
receive so if that's kicking the can
down the road I think what what I'm
hearing uh from the other side is uh is
kicking the can down the road further
discussion represent Damon
thank you Mr chair I Echo everything
representative luno said vigorously I
would also point out that it is not
fiscally responsible to do this because
children with food insecurity are twice
as likely to receive special ed services
twice as likely to retweet a grade have
increased hyperactivity and difficulty
focusing and they're twice as likely to
have behavioral issues that lead to
suspension so they cost more money when
they're not
fed it's it's unconscionable that we
can't figure out a way to go forward
with this further discussion from the
committee not seeing any hands uh Madam
CL or representative spills I I would
just like to state that every student
who is eligible can apply today
so further changes that Madam clerk
would you please call the
RO on this is 583 583 is a bill Rel to
State participation in the Medicaid
direct uh certification program for free
and reduced price School
meals representative spillsbury
yes representative Maguire yes
representative F yes representative
kofalt yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
Mah
again representative M yes
representative peoples yes
Representative luno no representative
Ames no representative Burton
no representative fellows
no representative Damon no
representative bricky absolutely not
Representative gritan no representative
Weinstein
no and chairman lad yes
10 Y and eight Nays
okay the majority report by represent
papovich and The Minority Report by I'll
do it represent
luno okay going on to the next bill on
the list here it's uh HB
646 yes will the minority motion be
otpa it will be um uh ought to pass okay
okay so going to the next bill requiring
school districts to establish an online
application for participation in the
free and reduced price meal program this
is HB 646 I'm going to pass the Gabel
off to representative spillsbury thank
you so on HB 646 I recognize
representative lad to make a motion yes
I make the motion of itl on
second second representative McGuire
and would you like to speak to your
motion just very very briefly 646 is a
bill which uh provides online
application for participation in the
free and reges program I know uh my
school district is doing this at at
currently uh without uh the need for the
legislation I know others in the state
are doing the same uh so uh if a school
district desires to put an online
application out for participation in and
reduced price meal program they they can
do so without the need for this
legislation
any further discussion representative
Weinstein um thank you Mr chair for uh
taking my question or my my comment um I
did put an amendment in it's not ready
yet um that would change the program um
removing the Mandate and making it a
grant program for districts to to be
reimbursed for the initial costs so I
heard from the
um business administrator in New Market
and the the cost for new market and it
varies widely throughout the state
because it depends on the on their um uh
platform that they use um so the cost in
New Market was about
$3,500 um and and then obviously with a
a additional annual uh costs for for the
um for the uh
process I'm not really sure what it is
um annual fee thank you um so um so at
this point in time there is a motion if
this is voted down then you can bring
your forward your your Amendment forward
okay it would go the other way so uh we
have a motion on the floor that's itls
and we need to take care of this motion
first so any further discussion on the
itl yes represent Lun yeah Mr chair so
um so given the fact that we've got an
an amendment um that has been outlined
by representative Weinstein would um and
that we're about ready to take a take a
vote on the motion would I guess I would
ask if there's if the chair is
interested in in looking at that
Amendment before taking a dispositive
motion on uh in committee um would we be
interested in maybe bumping this one to
the to the end of today or to the
February 25th EX Ive
session uh there there is a motion on
the floor right now and I'm I'm not
going to pull the motion back uh this is
the second going to pull it back no I
think we have a motion let's take care
of if this motion fails then you can
bring forward an another
motion Madam clerk please call the
role representative spillsbury
yes representative Maguire yes
representative F yes representative
kopal yes yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
Representative luno no representative
Ames no representative Burton no
representative bow no representative
Damon no representative bring no
Representative pran no representative
Weinstein no and chairman lad
yes 10 yay and eight
nay so the I will make go ahead
yeah okay so the vote being 10
to8 itl uh representative lad will write
the majority report who will write the
minority representa rep and OTP for OTP
okay very good that closes the exec
session on 646 okay the next bill up is
HB
665 this is a bill relative to
eligibility for the free School meals
program and I Look to representative
kcom for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I uh make a
motion to retain this
bill is there a second I'll second that
okay so we have a motion on the floor by
representa ccom to retain 665 and second
by represent luno represent kcom do you
have have anything to say no that's okay
I think that speaks for itself represent
luno no good okay any further discussion
from committee
members moving forward then with the
motion to retain on 665 when you're
ready Madam clerk representative spills
bearing yes representative Maguire yes
representative F yes representative
kofalt yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative Luna yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon no representative
bricky representative Ricky
no Representative kitan no
representative
Einstein
yes jman lad
yes so we have 11 yay and three nay so
153 sorry 153 and so that bill is
retained in
committee the next bill down on the dock
for today is
703 relative to prohibiting school
districts from denying meals to students
with unpaid meal Bank balances and
making an
appropriation
therefore uh represent peoples you're is
there an amendment for that okay we'll
have the amendment discussion I won't
take any motions on that Amendment first
and let's hear the the amendment
than
you okay uh representative uh Damon if
you're able would you speak to
the the amendment yes thank you Mr chair
so this is the second Amendment this is
043 excuse me
0434 which is replacing the bill and
it's replacing the prior amendment that
I brought forward last week um excuse me
and what it does is remove as the prior
Amendment did the section of the bill
wherein the Department of Education
would have been responsible for paying
off school district meal debt and
additionally it
removes lines of o
sorry it removes lines 20 through
22 of the original bill which is Clause
F pertaining to collections of school me
debt um so what the bill would now do is
require a policy statement by school
districts regarding fairness and not
shaming or
bullying students who have unpaid meal
balances and requiring school districts
to accept voluntary donations to
alleviate School Meal debt if that were
to be offered to them um there's no cost
to this bill it is simply a statement of
appropriate considerate Behavior to
students who through no fault of their
own are poor and have school meal debt
any further discussion from committee
members on the
amendment not see
any
okay then I'm going to look to represent
peoples for a
motion thank you chairman lad uh I want
to make a motion to um itl 63- fn- a
local um
I'm sorry
703 and the reason for that is that I
was hold on hold on hold on you need a
second here I'm sorry is there a second
to itl's and Madam Kirk we have a motion
made by representative peoples uh to itl
703 and second by represent Maguire
represent people is you're recognized to
speak to your
motion thank you chairman I was uh urged
by constituencies not to and the ability
for them to collect on student lunch
programs um it is a self-funded program
and this year our district it ran a
deficit there and many of the voters at
the school deliberative session were
there to to um talk about their
displeasure on us subsidizing it in that
way so I'm just following along with my
constituents and making motion to
itl represent McGuire do you have sure
um I I think that school districts
should they want to have the policy
that's in this amendment there's nothing
that prevents them from doing so right
so they have the they have the ability
if they want to adopt um the policy of
of not collecting in this way um they
can do
it further discussion from the committee
yes representative Damon thank you Mr
chair if I could represented people's I
need some
clarification
so I may be misunderstanding what you
just
said the amendment
removes the Clause prohibiting using a
collections agency are you indicating
that your
constituents would prefer that Clause
remain there or I'm I'm puzzled so I was
asked not to approve this bill because
they need to have every tool in their
toolbox in order to keep their program
running efficiently if they need to
collect money they they need to collect
that may I respond yes so the original
bill would not be responsive to what
your constituents requested because it
did does have a clause prohibiting using
a collections agency the amendment
removes
that so A School District would be fully
able to contract with a collection
agency should they choose to do
so if the amendment were put
forward and we would be ensuring that
every school district not just the ones
that are Forward Thinking enough to
create this policy but every school
district would be kind to poor children
who have meal
debt further discussion representative
Kon thank you Mr chair yes I'm still
um it's still a no deal for me on uh
item number G which authorizes the
school to complete applications for
students I think this this is a data
privacy issue and for that re reason I'm
supporting the
itl yes represent
Damon in response to representative
Cam's statement that is a federal
statute with it's just stating it here
as part of this policy it's not new it's
not
um we we can't not do that unless the
Federal Law
changes for represent luno thank you
very much Mr chair and and also I mean
when it when when we make statements
like like well school districts can
already adopt a policy should they want
to well I guess that would apply for all
School District policies however the
general court by law actually laws that
we've created I think require school
districts to adopt certain policies in
certain areas that's actually come out
of this um well out of the the former
House Education committee so where where
where the legislature feels feels maybe
um um something is so important and in
this case um you know it could be looked
at as as victim shaming students or
shaming students then then then what why
shouldn't the legislature uh adopt um uh
a law this bill to um to require school
districts to uh to not shame students
over um over meal debt uh we do it in a
lot of other areas and I think this is
an appropriate area
too further discussion representer
Damon I would like to ask my colleagues
who are opposed to this
bill if they believe that a b c d or e
are actually acceptable things for
schools To
Do Is there further discussion from the
committee represent
mahagan thank you Mr chairman and and I
hope that I can do this Justice um with
the 37 years of experience I had
watching the ladies in the lunchroom who
knew the children by name speak to each
of them by name with a care I know the
administrators have for each of the kids
in that school they don't need to told
how to treat each kid and each one is
treated individually shaming you don't
need to tell a teacher not to shame
their kid unless there's a problem in a
school and there you have a dysfunction
problem not a lunch problem thank
you further discussion from the
committee not seeing any we have a
motion on the floor and the motion is
for
itl Madam clerk 703
representative spills Barry yes
representative Maguire yes
representative F yes representative
kopal yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes represent
Brown yes representative mahagan yes
representative peoples yes
Representative luno no representative
Ames no representative Burton no
representative fellows no representative
Damon no representative Ricky no
Representative chrisan no represent of M
no J lad
yes Dan yes a
no
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah uh who's going
to write The Minority Report we yeah um
representative Damon for OTP and the
majority report you got okay that be
representative
peoples okay the next bill which on our
list is 656 I think we're going to pass
on that bill
today so we're going to go to it's not
it's not an early bill so we're going to
go to
771 uh this is relative to funding for
open enrollment schools I'm going to
pass the Gabel
off okay so for um HB 771 I recognize
representative lad for a motion yes I
I'd like to make the motion of
OTP OTP do we have a second
representative kofalt
seconds and would would you like to
speak to your motion yes I can briefly
speak to this um when I introduced this
this motion for or the bill for the
prime sponsor and those on it uh I I had
mentioned that this is an opportunity
and this bill is much different than
manifest education hardship much much
different this bill gives the parent the
right in a sending school to have their
child go to another school nearby
whether it be a public school in the
district or outside the district which
is an open enrollment school and it
provides the opportunity for parents to
take the advantage of the Open
Enrollment school which might have a
program of studies or a curriculum which
is more appropriate for their child that
they may see uh in the interest of the
child in the in the best interest of the
child and it's responsibility of the
sending District to place in their
budget the revenues for this and the
sending school does not need to be an
open enrollment School the receiving
school is the Open Enrollment school
thank you very
much further
comments yes representative luno yeah
thank you thank you very much so um so
you know we just talked about um what
districts can can do on their own uh or
what they can't do on their own and um
and one of the things this bill seems to
require is school districts to establish
a line item in their operating budget um
to reflect expenditures for open
enrollment schools so could um does
that then require school districts to um
to have to raise public tax money to to
be sent
to outside of the districts if somebody
wants to attend uh a different school I
mean what what are we what what are we
asking our taxpayers by that
line we're asking the taxpayers to
appropriate dollars to the education of
a child and whether the the dollars are
better used in a receiving school which
is an open enrollment school that ta
taxpayer dollar goes over 80% goes over
the other school and and the sending
School keeps the 20% so I I think it's a
a win-win for everybody and especially
the child who gets the education they
need
further questions or
comments okay seeing
none the clerk will call the role on the
OTP motion on HP
771 representative spillsbury
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
kofalt yes representative kcom yes yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative Luna no representative
Ames no representative Burton no
representative fellows no representative
Damon no no no president bricky no
president Quan no representative
Weinstein no my chairman lad
yes 10 yes and eight
no I'll do the majority
report bre and Luna are you going to be
doing I'll do the it okay thank you
sorry
okay okay the next bill which we have in
the dock it is
718 uh 718 requires State Board of
Education report the unfunded Financial
impact to school districts for rules
adopted by the board which exceed state
or federal minimum
standards and so I'm going to H hand the
gavel off to represent spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman um on uh hb7
18 I'm going to recognize representative
lad for a motion yes I'd like to make
the motion of
OTP OTP is the motion second from
representative
kofol and please speak to your motion
yes thank you very much RSC
186-16 C uh addresses rues succeeding
state or federal minimum requirements
that's in rule in law right now whenever
the State Board of Education proposes to
adopt or amend any special education
rule which exceeds the minimum
requirements of state or federal law the
State Board shall in addition to the
provisions of RSA 541a issue a report of
all such proposed rules which meets the
following requirements so that's already
in statute and the statute requires in
this report the annual report one the
rule number be stated number two the
nature of the rule must be stated number
three any any state minimum requirement
exceeded must be stated number four any
federal minimum requirement exceeded
must be
stated and and the next the reasons for
exceeding those minimum requirements
must also be stated what this bill does
it simply adds in as a sixth requirement
the following the unfunded Financial
impact on local school districts for
rules exceeding state or federal minimum
requirements so what this require re
Ires that this report also entail or
incorporate unfinancial impact unfunded
Financial impacts on the local school
district so that total would be there
and uh I believe this is necessary for
us to realize how what is going on in
terms of our exceeding uh I recognize
there's places where we do exceed for
good reason some areas of special
education however there's other areas
which I quite frankly think that we need
be more cognizant of and and understand
and and this is the way we will uh find
out that'll be it'll be placed in the
annual report which is given to the
state board and and to us thank
you further yes representative
Damon thank
you I'm concerned that a bill that is
about financial impact of rules doesn't
have a fiscal node in regards to the
cost of assessing and doing the work of
this
bill and I'm concerned that there are
very likely to be consequences that
result in lessening the standards that
New Hampshire takes pride in for
our better than the federal minimum
requirements I'm
opposed representative luno yeah thank
you very much Mr chair yeah I'm opposed
to um to 718 as well and uh well I think
on the um on it on its face you know
understanding which um which rules are
uh are unfunded um mandates
and goes goes beyond just identifying
the um the the rules that that exceed
state and federal um uh federal law so
in this case we're identifying the ones
that are unfunded by the state but are
actually funded by the um by our local
property taxpayers and and I think one
of the one of the things that that that
really jumps off the page to me is that
uh is that this puts us on a slippery
slope to low standards and no standards
which apparently which I think has been
a Hallmark of our Department of
Education despite the um the the fact
that our Public Schools perform among
the best in the
country representative P
Miller thank you Mr chair um I just
wanted to State on the record that I do
not share the concern expressed by my
colleague that reporting on the cost of
the rules that we adopt will somehow
lead to changes to the worse because I
think it is the duty of the legislature
to examine the consequences of its
actions when we pass laws or when we
approve rules we should look at their
costs and we should always keep an eye
towards whether the benefit achieved
through those rules are worth the cost
so this does nothing more than help us
do our job better and for that reason I
do not share those expressed concerns
thank you thank you are there further
comments seeing none I'll ask the Clark
to call the
rooll this is on the OTP motion for HP7
18 representative spills Barry yes
representative Maguire yes
representative F yes representative
kopal yes representative gocam yes
representative V Popovich sorry
yes representative Brown yes
representative mahagan yes
representative peoples yes
Representative luno no representative
Ames no representative Burton no
representative fellows no representative
Damon no Representative bricky no
Representative gritan no representative
Weinstein no Gman L
yes 10 yes eight n actually don't get
this okay the vote mean 10 yes uh eight
n OTP motion report will be written by
representative lad and a Minority Report
yes be Minority Report for it
representative Damon will write The
Minority Report itl thank
you we're not going to have a
so okay we're going to go back and and
take up now HB
770 this is relative to establishing a
program to earn tuition credits for
State of New Hampshire higher education
institutions through community service
and I Look to represent peoples for a
motion thank you chairman lad um I'd
like to make a motion to itl that
bill is there a
second thank okay uh represent uh
peoples makes the motion of itl and
second by representative Maguire uh this
is HB 770 itl uh represent peoples
would' you like to speak to your motion
please thank you chairman lad yes I
think right now with the current state
of the budget and creating another
program that would be a drain uh would
be a fiscal mistake that's why I made
the motion for
itail repon
McGuire do you have anything no passing
that further discuss question on this
represent luno thank you very much Mr
chair I would just like well I'm I'm I'm
sorry that um that 770 is uh is facing
the um the disposition of of itl um uh
and and I just want to uh want to thank
and congratulate uh both um uh Ryan
Casey and his sister Morgan for um
working
uh working diligently over the last two
years to uh to bring this bill forward
and working with representative Schultz
to uh to be the prime sponsor and uh
Ryan I think is in his junior year at
Bishop Brady Morgan is now in her first
year uh or second year now in in in
college and um and I think this has been
a great exercise in uh in leadership and
in Civics for both these um great
students and uh I hope they'll continue
to to work on it despite U what appears
to be its outcome today thank you thank
you further discussion representative
Burton uh yes thank you Mr chairman I
just wanted to point out that um we had
huge service learning programs at my
school and our research showed that
their grade point average went up
1.0 after they had been out in the
communities doing community service
because she they saw the relevance of of
the work they were doing and um so I I
would I favor this this program for that
reason that we
need people in the citizenry that really
appreciate doing public service thank
you further discussion from the
committee represent spillsbury I would
just like to Echo that I thought Ryan
Casey did a superb job for a young
fellow um in presenting I see a strong
future for him F to represent papovich
thank you Mr chair I just would like to
Echo the same positive comments and I
just want to State on the record what I
said off the camera after the
presentation of that was one of the most
impressive presentations for a bill that
I've seen from a young member of you
know our state and uh that was just
spectacular
work thank you further discussion not
see any um Madam clerk would you please
call the rooll on HB 71 or
770 representative spillsbury
yes representative Maguire yes
representative F yes representative
copal yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
Representative luno no representative
Ames no representative Burton no
representative fellows no representative
Damon no representative Ricky no
Representative gritan no representative
Weinstein no chairman lad
yes 10 yes and eight
no okay uh there'll be a Minority Report
written by there will by Ron Burton by
Ron
Burton
and okay so that the that takes care of
where we are
today um we will meet again Tuesday next
week and uh we have a number of bills
which are all the the funding type stuff
um and we will have some other bills on
there which uh may carry forward then we
may exec so we may exec so if you're
going to be absent please let your your
caucus or your leadership know that you
may not be here and you will need a sub
so that be Tuesday next next week and
then we meet again the following Tuesday
um for that be the 4th of March where we
going to have absolutely get all the
early bills out of
committee further yes represent luno so
thank you very much Mr chair seeing as
there's no um uh house session next week
when would you like to have committee
reports um so I I guess I would like to
you know not crowd you and say you got
to be in by noon tomorrow but uh if
they're in by you know I'll give about
two or three days get those things done
and get them to me sounds good yeah
right by Friday that'd be good okay
great than you very much Mr that'd be
good anybody
else thank you very much and have a good
afternoon okay so thanks thanks
all
right
res on
Tuesday
e e